[Music]
the latest storms brought
unwanted trash across the valley the
regional flood control district says
debris is often trapped in channels
sometimes trapping the water as well
sally jaramillo has been driving around
town checking out the issue
sally kirsten while past storms have
brought us a lot of rain to the las
vegas valley it's also bringing
a whole lot of trash here now i want you
to check this channel out all day long
we've seen
shoes water bottles containers landscape
and more
hearing f with the regional flood
control district says whenever we have
good rain
all the trash compiles in the flood
control system we have a total of 677
miles of channels
washes and we are seeing trash
everywhere due to what neff describes
as a mountain of debris she says they
require from bulldozers
bulldozers and dump trucks to clear it
all out nefads they have trash racks in
their channels to trap the debris that
piles up
all in order to keep it out of the lake
their engineers and hydrology team have
been on the field today and seeing all
that trash
they're busy they're out there sweeping
streets they're keeping storm drains
clean and now they have all of this to
maintain because the next storms could
hit us on friday
neff says they have seen a substantial
increase in the amount of debris caused
by people experiencing homelessness
but also remind everyone living here to
please do their part
and not litter now if you see trash
around your neighborhood
you can also report that that
information you can find it on our
website eightnewsnow.com for now
reporting live sally jaramillo 8 news
now